what's up elimination it's Evan my one
word is believe and I believe in you I
believe you have an amazing gift inside
you that I want to see exploded onto the
world that'll help you on your journey
today we're gonna look at seven ways to
instantly make your life more positive
[Music]
so one of the things I get asked a lot
by entrepreneurs is how do I stay
positive because it's hard being an
entrepreneur is really really hard
there's so many obstacles that come
infront of us as so many people who tell
us we can't do it we've got our own
voices in our head saying this is never
going to work Who am I to think I can do
this big thing always constantly
doubting ourselves and so the ones who
win are the ones who stay positive who
even though all of this crazy stuff is
happening around them they still find a
way to stay positive and keep going and
so today I'm going to share with you my
seven ways on how you can stay positive
if you are in a rut way number one and
maybe the most important is stop seeking
approval this one is really tough a lot
of times we're doing things because we
want to look good in somebody else's
eyes we want to make our parents power
we want to do the thing that in the
magazines are doing or some celebrity is
doing and we're only working off of
making other people happy and that is
the fastest way to being unhappy there's
maybe not a faster way to get to a
negative place because you're never
living your version of your life you're
trying to photocopy somebody else's life
there's a great line by Quincy Jones
who's a legendary music producer who
said not one ounce of my self-worth
comes from your opinion of me and I
think that's a really powerful way to
live your life if you could live your
life and go off and do the things that
are scary for you the things that you
really want to do but you're afraid of
failing in front of somebody else you're
afraid of what somebody's opinion of you
might be if you can ignore that and move
through it allows you to do so many
powerful things a quick story I was on a
ski lift going up to the top I'm doing
my snowboard practice and I see this
girl trying to do these jumps on the
hill and I want her to jump I want him
to jump every time she jumps she falls
every time she jumps she falls
so finally she's at the bottom of the
hill I'm at the top of the lift I'm
looking down and she finally hits it the
last jump she hits it and I'm secretly
cheering inside like she did it it's
awesome I get to the top of the hill now
I get off the ski oolitic I'm starting
to come down I think huh I wonder if I
could do a jump like that little girl
who was doing jumps inspired me I wonder
if I could do that jump and the first
thought that came into my head was what
if I fall like who's here who's watching
and thinking I was just on the ski lift
cheering this girl on silently and now
I'm afraid of how people will judge me
and so it's so crazy how much we
restrict ourselves and hold ourselves
back because we're worried about how
other people will see us and so learning
to catch that as soon as I get a thought
of how I might be perceived by somebody
and if that's holding me back then I
have to lean into it more as soon as I'm
afraid of speaking here when there's
people walking by right as soon as I'm
afraid then I have to do it more because
it builds that muscle and so whenever
you feel yourself playing small or
shrinking down because you're worried of
somebody else's opinion of you then you
have to go and do that thing and doesn't
mean you get in their face and you're
angry towards them or you have to you
know be super bold in their face and
offend them it just means you're doing
your thing and you don't care what other
people's opinion of you are way number
two is to run into your problems we
don't like problems right in general as
humans we don't like problems we want to
run away from them we want to hide from
them we don't want to address them we
want to feel safe in our cocoon and just
not have to deal with the outside world
but that's not a great way to live a
positive way because that problem is
likely not going to go away and I find
such great satisfaction and joy from
running into the problem so whenever
there is a problem you develop that
identity that I'm the kind of person who
solves problems that I'm the kind of
person who handles difficult situations
that I'm the kind of person who will
have that tough conversation with
somebody because you always feel better
after you've solved it whatever problem
you're facing right now is weighing on
you it's really negative and toxic
energy that you're carrying around with
you every day and the longer that lasts
the more negative you're gonna get just
go and solve the problem have that
difficult conversation deal with that
tough person solve the problem as best
you can to get it off your shoulders
and move forward and again it's just
developing that identity developing that
having that practice that anytime a
difficult situation comes up anytime
that there's a problem you are the
person who is going to jump forward and
solve it way number three is live your
version of your life at some point you
have to figure this out you know as
you're growing up as you're making your
way through life you are living your
life according to other people you're
living your parents life they're guiding
you they're telling you what is right
and what is wrong but at some point you
need to outgrow that maybe that happens
when you're 14 maybe that happens when
you're 18 maybe that happens when you're
30 hopefully you're not still 45 and
still only doing something because your
parents want you to do it you need to at
some point decide this is my life I'm
going to decide and I will deal with the
consequences like maybe that means your
parents kick you out of the house so you
have to live with that and you have to
go and forge your own path but if you
are living your parents life and you get
to stay at home then you can't complain
you have to make the choice at some
point that I am breaking free from other
people's expectations I'm not going to
live my parents life or my grandparents
life or my friends or what my guidance
counselor wants me to do this is my
version of my life I'm gonna take
responsibility for it and I'm gonna make
it awesome way number four is create a
morning routine I think this is so
important especially for entrepreneurs
what I see with entrepreneurs happening
so often is we get excited we get fired
up we're all ambitious and motivated and
then you're on fire for the rest of the
day and then you fall down the next day
you wake up and like where did that
energy go and you've lost a mojo in the
omentum and for whatever reason it's
gone and you constantly see
entrepreneurs start and stop and start
and stop and start and stop is like if
you could just stay consistent you will
make amazing things happen and so for me
part of that is creating the morning
routine you know what makes you feel
bold you know what makes you come alive
maybe it's watching one of these videos
maybe it's reading a passage from the
Bible maybe it's hugging your dog like
whatever the thing is that gets you
feeling old and unstoppable then do that
every single morning like start your day
with that so that you can be bold from
the beginning if you live your life for
the next year doing the thing that made
you
feel bold and unstoppable every single
morning your life would be
unrecognizable from where it is today
and so create that morning routine you
already know the thing that gets you
excited
put that every day so that you start
with it so that you can set yourself up
for success when number five is change
your environment you are a product of
your environment you're a product of the
people that you hang out with the habits
that you have the routines that you have
and I look at two things here one your
physical environment so if you look at
my home office I've got people on my
wall right these giant canvases of
people on my wall that means something
to me
those people may not mean anything to
you but I walk in there and it means
something to me
also the people who are in your life the
people who you hang out with if you're
hanging around negative toxic people all
the time
it's really really really hard to stay
positive the benefit of an environment
and creating one that really supports
and builds you up is that it's automatic
you don't have to think about it every
day it's really hard to every morning
think and wake up like yes I'm going to
tackle the day like that's not how most
people at least wake up it's not how I
wake up if you design an environment one
time that allows you to build that
boldness and excitement then it happens
automatically for you every day I just
have to walk into my office and I see
the things on the wall I just have to
wake up and go to the bathroom and I
read a page from the book it's why I
created the top 10 was a success that
every day I would read one page from the
book and feel bold and feel motivated
and that's how we start my morning every
single day and so again the things that
get you feeling bold excited you want to
put it into your environment your
physical environment and the people that
you were hanging around on a consistent
basis because those people will
automatically trigger your excitement
automatically trigger your confidence
which is so badly needed if you want to
stay positive
[Music]
when number six is accept responsibility
one of the things that I see over and
over and over again in successful
entrepreneurs is that they accept
responsibility
everything is their fault everything is
my fault everything wrong with my
youtube channel every mistake that's
made by myself or my team is my fault
every mistake at TDS is my fault if alex
sucks in front of a class one day is my
fault you accept the responsibility
where most people what they do is they
want to blame they want to blame the
person to say Alex what happened you
sucked at night what happened you're
just a terrible instructor right ah it's
my fault and when you stop blaming other
people when you stop putting it on Alex
or putting it on your team or putting it
on the president or putting it on the
bank or putting on your parents and
putting on the government when you stop
placing the blame and other people and
you accept the responsibility first that
kind of sucks the think that everything
is my fault wow that sucks because it's
great to have somebody else to blame I
would love to blame Alex follow my
problems but really it's my fault but
the second thing it does once you get
through that initial period of suckiness
is it's really empowering because it
means if you're in charge you can go and
change something if you don't like
something in your life you have the
power to change it and make it better
and so that is super empowering where
you can stop blaming other people around
you the school system and the president
everybody else and take full
accountability for where you are in life
and where you are going to be anyway
number seven is to start immediately one
of the most important things you could
ever do when you have a goal is to take
some kind of immediate action towards
achieving that goal this is where so
many entrepreneurs mess up they create a
goal they get excited they're watching a
video like this like yes this is amazing
I'm gonna go write all these goals for
myself here's everything I'm going to
accomplish and starting tomorrow I'm
gonna go crush it and then they wake up
tomorrow and say ah I can't do that Who
am I to do that that's great I was crazy
yesterday I can't actually do those
things on that list I'm gonna just fall
back to where I was and keep living my
crappy life right that's what we end up
doing to ourselves as soon as you set a
goal you need to take some kind of
immediate
action towards accomplishing it even
better is if you can involve somebody
else in it you have this idea of this
new product you want to launch email a
friend's or email a client your email
potential supplier and set up a meeting
for tomorrow or for the next week to sit
down with them and talk about it because
you're going to show up to that meeting
you've created the momentum and when you
commit to somebody else you're much more
likely to eating you it happening going
forward and so the next time you set a
goal whether it's tonight whether it's
right now whether it's tomorrow morning
whenever you set your next goal for
yourself some small form of immediate
action towards achieving it don't worry
about it if it's perfect or not if it
goes to be a youtuber get out your phone
and just make a video right now
stop waiting just go and yes you can
make it better you can get a studio you
can get a friend to film you but you're
gonna get in your own way and that's
never gonna happen so make it happen
right now in the smallest form to build
up momentum as soon as you set a goal
take immediate action in some small way
towards achieving it so those are my
seven ways on how to make your life
instantly more positive I would love to
know from you which one of the seven
ways resonated the most with you you're
gonna try to apply to your life
immediately did I miss an eight nine 10
that you want to add to the list please
leave it down the comments below thank
you guys so much for watching I believe
in you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself in whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon if you had
to think of one word that's most
important to or that sums you up or that
would be like a little beacon hey
believe nation if you want to know what
the most important one word is for Tony
Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey
will.i.am and Howard Schultz I have a
very special secret video for you check
the description for details